physics chemistry optimization machine learning and other subjects and it can be expressed in several different but
equivalent ways one way to express it is to say that a matrix row is positive semi-definite if there exists a matrix M
such that row is equal to M dagger time M and it turns out that it doesn't matter if we demand that M itself is a
square Matrix or if we drop that restriction another way to express what it means for a matrix row to be positive
semi-definite is to say that row is herian which means that it's equal to its own conjugate transpose and all of
its I values are non- negative real numbers in general herian matrices can
only have real number igen values but they can be negative but if we include the additional restriction that none of
the igen values can be negative we obtain the positive semi-definite matrices and by the way if you're given
a matrix and you want to know if it's positive semi-definite then you can determine that by using this characterization it's quite easy to
check whether or not a matrix is heran that's something that can just be eyeballed it's more difficult to compute
the igen values but that's something that's not too difficult to do with a computer because there are very efficient algorithms to do
it and the last characterization that I'll mention although there are others is that for every column Vector s having
a number of entries that agrees with the number of rows and the number of columns of row the inequality shown on the
screen is true in words drai time row time catchi must be a non- negative real
number it's not obvious by the way that these characterizations are all equivalent but they are and let me note explicitly that the
notation that we commonly use to indicate that a matrix row is positive semi-definite looks like row is greater
than or equal to zero but this is just a shorthand notation and it doesn't literally mean that row is greater than
or equal to zero row is a matrix so that wouldn't make sense and it does not mean
that each of the entries of row is greater than or equal to zero in particular there are positive
semi-definite matrices whose entries aren't all non- negative and there are matrices whose entries are all non-
negative but they aren't positive semi-definite the idea behind the notation is that positive semi-definite
matrices are like Matrix analoges of non- negative real numbers but this is just notation and what it means is
precisely what we've already discussed now let's take a look at a few examples starting with an example of a
positive semi-definite Matrix in fact it's quite easy to randomly generate an example of a
positive semi-definite matrix by simply choosing a matrix M arbitrarily and then Computing M dagger time
M for example here's a matrix M that's not particularly special and in fact I
randomly generated this matrix by independently choosing the real and imaginary parts of the entries to be integers between negative 9 and positive
9 so any patterns or structure here is purely coincidental by multiplying the
conjugate transpose of M to M we get this Matrix right here which is therefore positive
semi-definite of course there's a limit to how much Insight we can gain from a random example but it does exhibit some
features that are common to positive semi-definite matrices more generally in particular you'll notice
that the diagonal entries meaning the ones along the line from the upper left to the lower right are all non- negative real
numbers and moreover the off diagonal entries are somehow not too large compared to the corresponding diagonal
entries meaning the one in the same row and the one in the same column as whatever off diagonal entry we're looking
at there is more to the story than this though and it's important to recognize that being positive semi-definite is a
property of a matrix as a whole and not just a condition on individual end entries so that's an example of a
positive semi-definite Matrix and you can very easily generate other examples through a similar
methodology now let's take a look at some examples of density matrices where in addition to the positive semidefinite condition we also have that the trace is
equal to one here are some examples of 2x two density matrices the trace is equal to
one in all four cases and we can also see that these are herian matrices so using the second characterization of
positive semi-definite matrices from before All That Remains is to check that the igen values are all non- negative
I'll leave that for you to check if you wish for 2x two matrices it isn't too difficult to compute igen values by hand
but you can also just ask a computer to do it for example you can use the igen Val function in the linear algebra
package for python we can also obtain a density matrix by simply taking any nonzero
positive semi-definite Matrix and dividing it by its trace for example here's the density Matrix we get by
dividing the example we saw just a few moments ago by its Trace dividing by the trace like this
will always preserve the positive semi-definite property and we'll certainly obtain a matrix having Trace equal to one by virtue of the fact that
the trace is a linear function that's just a small collection of examples and we'll see more as the
lesson continues next we take just a few moments to discuss the interpretation or
intuitive meaning of density matrices the first thing to acknowledge is that it may seem a little bit unusual
that we're representing the state of a system with a matrix rather than a vector in contrast in the simplified
formulation of quantum information we use vectors to represent States whereas matrices specifically unitary matrices
represent actions or operations this is just the way the ma mathematics works and although you can
always think about matrices as describing linear mappings we don't typically associate a direct intuitive
meaning to the linear mapping associated with a given density Matrix having said that the fact that
density matrices are indeed matrices does turn out to be a critically important aspect of them and we'll see
that as we continue on but to briefly mention just one example for now the igen values of a given density Matrix
turn not to be very important because they describe how much Randomness or uncertainty is inherent to the state
that that density Matrix describes a different way to think about density matrices at an intuitive level
focuses on the entries of these matrices remember that the rows and Columns of density matrices are placed
in correspondence with the classical States of Whatever system we're talking about so for each entry we have one